[Music]
okay
let's go we're white against izola
let's get a d4 and i want to play
something positional
i want to focus
in this part of the speed run on on
positional concepts so d4 e6 this is a
very commonly misunderstood move
obviously um
black allows a transition to the french
defense but if you don't play one e4
then there's no need
and really no point in
uh in transitioning to the french
because you don't know maybe your
opponent does play the french against c4
so if you're a d4 player and you want to
you know you want to play main lines you
just go c4 anyway there's no reason not
to
okay it goes d6 so this is already very
weird d6 and e6 uh i mean i hope he's
not going to start trolling us
so
just like in e4 openings you handle this
in exactly the same way you occupy
a part of the center and then you
develop your pieces quickly now there's
a couple of ways to proceed here we can
go e4
and control more of the center we could
just develop our knights it doesn't
matter let's just go knight c3 test the
waters let's see what he does
okay bishop b7 very passive
nothing
horrible about what he's doing it's just
tremendously passive
so i would propose going e4 and building
up a three pawn center
um
and you know we're trying to punish him
but as i always say there's a balance to
be found between controlling the center
with pawns and then developing our
pieces so
um
we could toe the line by playing f4 i
would probably play f4 in one of my
games but
what i recommend to players in this
raiding range is to try to master that
balance
and uh and to not push that envelope
it's much better to make sure that your
pieces are developed and your center is
well protected are then to go crazy and
start occupying the center with you know
five or six pawns and then you know get
overextended so let's not reinvent the
wheel here let's just go knight f3 and
develop our pieces casually c6 okay so
he continues to play
very weird
very weird moves so how should we
continue what you know who can propose
um
a follow-up means of development where
should we put our pieces again let's
play as unoriginally as possible just
put pieces on reasonable looking squares
yeah i would like i would prefer bishop
d3
um because this bishop i don't know
where it's going to go here's the thing
if he plays knight f6
this bishop might want to jump out to g5
right that should make sense so
um
so it should also make sense that we are
delaying the development of this bishop
um until he puts his cards on the table
but this bishop on f1 we don't need to
delay its development because we already
know where it can go
um and the reason i prefer d3 over e2
largely concerns itself with the fact
that on d3 it controls the e4 pawn and
if we later play e5 i've described this
idea before
uh you can imagine that it's going to be
aiming at the h7 pawn uh so it has in
other words a lot of potential energy
uh okay so now we castle
i'm gonna play that move pretty quickly
yeah so
you know
we need to be very patient against these
kinds of setups because if we strike in
the center too early maybe some of you
are like let's go you know let's go
after him let's go d5
d5 looks very good but i don't think
it's that good after e5 it just allows
him to close down the center so
remember that you only have often times
one
sort of try
when you're trying to punish your
opponent and so you want to be well
prepared for it you don't want to strike
willy-nilly and prematurely so
what kind of move comes to mind
which might gear you up for the center
getting open and i think one of you has
already proposed it let's put the rook
on e1 not only does it help prepare the
move e5 but if we play d5 and the center
opens up our rook is going to be well
poised okay so he goes g5 and now the
time has come to step on the gas pedal
right clearly
he's continuing to abandon his
development
and this is how intuition works my
intuition is now screaming all right
daniel you got to do something if we
don't do anything i mean he is going to
go g4 and the opportunity train is going
to you know stop at the station and then
it's going to
uh pass on
forward so we have
you know two realistic ways of breaking
through in the center we can go d5 or e5
d5 i just pointed out is not very good
because he can go e5
now who can explain to me
why
e5 d5 is a better version of the
position for white
then correspondingly
us playing d5 and him playing e5 that
can be a little bit difficult to
perceive it's an instructive
difference i'm going to play e5 in the
meantime because of the time situation
and i anticipate him playing d5
so we keep the center pawns
we block the development of the knight
on g8 it cannot go to f6 that's very
significant right
and we open up more of the position
after d5 cdcd
uh we open up the c file
and also this sort of fringe structure
is just a lot more desirable for white
than the sort of king's indian structure
that would have arisen after d5 e5 i'll
show this after the game
but this should be intuitively clear to
most people
all right
so we have many good moves here white is
positionally just completely winning
here his bishop is dead this is like a
horrific french
a lot of you are thinking about knight
b5 knight b5 is a good move
um nothing wrong with it but he would
drop his queen back for example to b8
and i think it would be premature to go
to d6 remember he's got a bishop on e7
that's guarding that square
so again in such positions it often pays
to play either very prophylactically
take the sting out of whatever threats
he has remaining or
play very simple chess don't
um you don't have to
do something crazy or unoriginal in fact
i think the strongest players
often play such positions in this in the
simplest possible manner you you bring
out pieces you put them on good squares
so i have two ideas the first is to go
bishop d2 or bishop e3
bishop d2 believe it or not is kind of a
blunder who can tell me why you have to
be attentive to every source of danger
he's got a pawn on g5 i'm keeping an eye
on it where can it go i can go to g4
this knight has only one escape square
on d2 so maybe you guys are thinking now
well maybe it's worth playing h3 and
stopping g4 first but i'm not sure
that's a very efficient use of our
resources g4 is not dangerous provided
that we keep the d2 square alive and so
i like bishop e3
i also like queen a4 as many of you are
indicating just to tie up this knight
let's start with bishop e3 let's start
with the most flexible move and we're
not playing this move to get this bishop
active we're playing this move to get
the rook involved in the game with rook
c1 which is what we're down doing
and look at how well coordinated our
pieces are and how paralyzed he is
we're gonna have to speed up our pace a
little bit queen a5 now
what i'm doing here is i'm looking for
inroads into his position we might be
tied into the queen side well let's look
at the king side as well does he have
any weak squares on the king's side
well wouldn't we want a queen to drop on
h5
just to attack him from the other side
that's just something which my pattern
recognition kind of revealed because
i've done this before
so we play knight d2 on our own volition
in order to pave the way for queen h5
and that's going to be devastating
position
ultimately is going to collapse from one
side or the other side there's going to
be tactics that start manifesting
themselves here queen h5 if he goes b4
we have a pretty sexy sequence
now what am i thinking about as i put my
queen on h5 i'm already thinking about a
particular tactic here first of all
thank you long shot
i'm thinking about
the idea of doing something along this
diagonal because this is a pin
and
what is it that we could do well we
could attack the f7 pawn directly i
don't see how yet but there is a very
common tactical pattern removing the
guard
as many of you are indicating the idea
which is a threat of knight takes d5e
takes d5 and then e6 that is a very very
typical pattern in such situations
so and and the other typical pattern is
to is to sack the bishop which is bishop
g6 basically breaking the chain
and infiltrating then with the queen
which is a little bit riskier
another very simple idea by the way guys
if you consider the other benefits of
putting the queen on h5 what is the
other thing the queen is doing which may
seem completely insignificant it might
seem like okay what who cares about this
thing
but if i forced you to make another
observation about what the queen is
accomplishing it's pinning the h-bond
again who gives the care about that well
i do
because this g5 fund could be suffering
as a direct result of that if perhaps we
can take it with our bishop not yet
because he's going to take back he's
made an excellent move that if it's a
good defensive move
um
and we have many different ways of
proceeding here
many different ways of proceeding we can
go knight b3 and transfer our knight you
know somewhere to c5
but um
as many of you guys are indicating i
love the move knight back to f3 simply
threatening to capture on g5 and
breakthrough
and we're basically forcing his queen
back to d8
so his position is very hard to crack i
mean he's
doing a phenomenal job of
doing defending but
if we keep you know the gas pedal foot
on the gas pedal
we're eventually going to find some
inroads into his position we don't have
to rush he's totally paralyzed
and you know if your opponent defends
against the immediate threats the only
thing that you you know you can do
is find ways to accumulate the pressure
and
simultaneously look for tactics on every
move
so it's both things are important okay
rook h10 there comes the collapse
that's obviously
a blunder now
notice how i'm not taking immediately
i'm just taking a moment okay do i have
any better moves i don't see anything
better let's just take
and once the first material losses are
sustained
now you need to strike while the iron is
still hot okay
the king side is now
a lot more weakened now that the rook is
gone so
immediately the question you should be
asking yourself is what do do i have the
capability of opening up ripping open
the king side particularly because this
queen
is god knows where on the other side and
of course we do we have the move h4 i
know that some of you might be thinking
but aren't we weakening our king
and remember my analogy in such cases if
a tree falls in a forest and nobody's
there nobody hears it does it produce a
noise
he has literally no firepower anywhere
near our king
our king can take its clothes off and
chill
uh you know on the balcony of his castle
um
you know we don't care we literally
don't care
okay b4 so obviously we can even take on
g5 perhaps and sack the knight no need
for us to do that why not just drop the
knight back
okay so he takes on a2 this i don't give
a about
we just play hg
and now we're threatening just to break
through with g6 and win the game that's
what's going to happen he's going to
take b2 i think and then we're going to
go g6 now notice that i'm not playing
ghgh is fine but g6 you get more bang
for your buck because you're forcing
this f7 pawn to collapse which if you
remember which was our initial plan so
we we are able
to
extract the benefit both benefits from
the queen being on h5 first we attack
the g5 fund and now we extract the
secondary benefit which is the queen's
pressure on f7 or the primary benefit
depending on how you're looking at it
okay so
very patient
don't grab the pawn on f7 immediately
wait a minute the knight's defending we
need to take the knight first doesn't
matter which piece we take it with just
take with the knight don't lose you know
don't lose sleep over
these kinds of things
this is a bit of an obscure weakness
that i see in some players is
these very insignificant decisions they
will spend a very long time on there are
some things that objectively do not
matter
and objectively you kind of need to
eenie meenie my nemo the the only reason
i took with the knight because was
because the queen and the knight are
objectively the stronger attacking
tandem but both of us would have been
good okay now we just start taking
everything queen takes e6
and it's going to be checkmate in a
couple of moves
on the next move we're going to take
that knight with check and then we're
going to
see where that leads
okay so we have checkmate and two after
he plays game d7 who can find the maiden
two was very pretty sequence
checkmate in two moves
um a little bit of practice now of
course if you don't see mate you can
just take on t5 and take the
take the last truck
but as many of you are indicating e6
track force is the king to d6 and it is
the bishop and i love when this happens
a piece that sort of was sitting dormant
for most of the game all of a sudden it
you know
it's like being the lab partner and
uh doing all the work but then your your
partner who did nothing gets all the
glory
um
except in this case that's kind of a
good thing
that was a very pretty game yeah um that
was nice
and i think it's a good lesson in thank
you for the 100 in you know how to
punish
passive
but not truly passive just pass a very
passive opening play
so
one of the benefits of
one of the benefits of e4 openings over
d4 openings they
there's less of the stuff that my
opponent played in e4 openings because
if you kind of try to do the same thing
if you play like well if you play an
analogous
sequence of moves
you're going to get crushed a lot faster
because
um how should i explain it your play is
oriented more toward the king side so
it's you're less likely to get away with
something like this there's going to be
quicker
central breakthroughs than there are in
d4 opening so if you're a d4 player it
really is important to know how to break
down this kind of passive play because
this will also be applicable in
legitimate openings that tend to be on
the passive side such as the old indian
or certain cramped openings just knowing
how to play in those positions is
important
all right so e6 c4
again if
you play both d4 and e4
it makes and you're confident in your
abilities in the french you can play e4
and transpose
but we kept the integrity of the sort of
d4 opening so here by the way there's a
very interesting system bishop before
check
which is not really a nimzo indian it's
sort of a cross
and this has its own theory i mean and
actually it has quite a lot of theory
this may or may not transpose
into one of several openings this may be
a bogo indian
you know it it may be its own opening
maybe nimzo indium
uh something to investigate if you're
looking for some cool
sidelines for black and you're okay
playing the french
not really the raven i'm not really sure
what you're getting so d6 again is
obviously passive knight c3
e4 this is all normal
um
knight f3
and again f4
very much possible as an alternative but
we decided to adopt a more moderate
approach c6 bishop d3
h6
um castle this is self-explanatory but
you guys can ask questions
about this part of the game if you'd
like so
yeah so queen c7 rookie one
now why again let me address very
quickly the point why are we first of
all why are we not playing bishop f4
there was a specific reason i didn't
like bishop f4
uh and if this reason didn't exist then
we would have done it does anybody well
there's two reasons actually
and
um
can somebody name one of them
yeah so the first one is e5
so we walk into
this move which almost transposes into
sort of an old indian and the second is
is g5 on a similar note
and you know these positions you could
get in trouble in if you're not careful
very quickly he's already threatening h4
and stuff and
you know it can be easy to forget that
even though he's very cramped the pawns
can still do the heavy lifting here if
that makes sense
so i didn't like that
and i didn't really like bishop e3
because it's a little bit you know we're
blocking
access to these central squares uh from
our heavy pieces
and that's not what we're trying to
accomplish here
so rookie one right we're delaying the
pawn push we're preparing e5
and we're waiting for him to show his
cards so if he goes knight f6 then we
definitely go e5 striking in the center
with tempo
something like this could happen now we
go bishop f4 it's a different story the
knight on g4 is stuck we're threatening
h3
um so how do i know not to push yet well
you can calculate i mean you can look at
d5 and conclude that after e5 nothing
good happens
um you can calculate e5 and you can see
that the simply blunder is a positive
this isn't like a mysterious intuition
the intuition is based on very specific
uh evaluation but i'm also
instinctively going rookie one i'm not
literally always calculating these
options
g5 and e5 so there's a very common
dictum in chess which says if your
opponent plays on the flank you strike
in the center i'm sure you guys have
probably heard of this
uh many times and it's
you know among principles it's one of
the best principles it holds true
a tremendous amount of time you know a
large majority of the time
and where does it stem from well it
stems from the fact that if your
opponent is playing on the flank not
only is he probably making weaknesses
um but probably also
you know but probably also diverting
attention from the center of the board
so i think it's quite an intuitive
principle so e5
this no longer blunders upon that's why
we get that's why we want rookie one
and d5
so if d takes e5 who can tell me
which way would we have captured on e5
important question and here you have to
be concrete calculate
yeah i'm glad to hear thank you for
formidable blue
[Music]
blue yeah
knight e5 yeah not d e
don't allow g4
separating the knight from the pawn this
is fine for white but why allow it when
you can just take with the knight
and look at the diagonal that has been
also created by the queen the light
squares are tremendously weak just like
in the game the d6 square
we would try to get the knight involved
i mean this is just absolutely
horrendous quite like in the game
d5vd
so if he had gone ed we would have gone
e6 probably
and broken through
with far greater ease so of course he
wants cd
thank you formidable blue
for
for me to blue for the five gifted i
really appreciate it damn girl
ma mayan
i really really appreciate it thank you
and i think the most instructive part of
the game was here because
i i think that a lot of players struggle
with patience in these types of
positions
which is why a lot of you were tempted
to go knight p5 a move that i don't
dislike
uh
but
you know it's not i think this is knight
b5 is the best move in this position but
i was trying to illustrate a greater a
larger concept which is that you know in
positions where your opponent is so out
of counter play
it really pays to complete your
development and make moves that look
very bland and boring
so that
you can once the decisive invasion
starts you have the firepower necessary
uh for everything to
run smoothly thank you derek wu
now knight b5 would have been very
strong as well because after something
like queen b8
if we pay very careful attention to the
c7 square we might notice the move queen
to c2 to be honest with you guys i
missed this move and i was looking at an
ip5
um and it's very hard for black to spot
to stop knight c7 because of course if
bishop d a then this square is weak
and king d8 is tremendous i mean that's
probably what he would have
what he would have had to do
but now that's a massive concession
obviously
um
no there is a definite i mean weaknesses
are squares that cannot be protected by
pawns
but not all weaknesses are relevant and
to spot relevant weaknesses you have to
have a sense of
where your pieces belong right and where
your pieces are going to be
um fulfilling their maximal capabilities
and that is tied into pattern
recognition and experience okay so we
decided on a more patient approach
bishop e3 rook c1 and knight d2
so how did i know to play knight t2 so
the thing is
i don't think the sack on d5 works
we've basically made all of the possible
improving moves on the queen side we've
gotten the rook to c1
and
one of the most common ways of winning
such position close positions where one
side is totally out of counter play is
to switch your attention to the other
side of the board even aaron nimsovich
talked about this in my system you do as
much as you can on one side of the board
you distract your opponent's attention
and then you find weaknesses on the
other side of the board and occupy those
and that's a form of a principle of two
weaknesses your opponent gets
overwhelmed
uh and and ultimately this leads to some
some sort of uh resolute tactical
resolution hence knight d2
b5 queen h5
um
had he played b4
we would have had a very pretty sequence
of moves now i mentioned in the game of
course
um
the idea of knight takes d5
he takes d5 e6 this should be very
obvious to people i mean look at how
crushing this is but of course knight
takes d5 is impossible
because of queen takes d5 right
but what if you were to ask yourself the
sam shanklin question what's the sam
shanklin question what happens if i do
it anyway could we go 1965 or not
nice we can still go knight takes d5
because of bishop e4
and this skewers the queen to the rook
queen has to move somewhere i mean queen
a52 doesn't matter we take the rook the
game is over not only have we won the
exchange but now the bishop is toast as
well
so that was a very nice line i was
hoping this would happen
uh in addition we could play knight b3 a
little intermediate move
chasing the queen away from its
protection of d5 and then still knight
e5 and e6 is totally crushing so we had
an alternative if you didn't see that
okay
so that didn't happen he played knight
f8
and now we go knight f3 this is totally
winning
we are threatening
to take on g5 now his
last
resort would have been to play queen d
this was the most sensible it's a sad
move to play
and
how would we have proceeded in this
position well
there are a million ways to win this
game there's a million ways to get to
the weaknesses in his position the
simple plan
could be to double rooks on the c file
that comes to mind
um another maneuver that comes to mind
is this is going to be really cool
knight b1
who can tell me where the knight is
going
it's going to c5 it's going to c5 to
simply overwhelm black's resources
defensive resources black is paralyzed
if we can get this bishop out of the
picture then the pawn on g5 once again
becomes very weak notice that this rook
on a shade is it's permanently
undefended it's not like he can
he can engineer a situation where the
rook is defended so
the pawn on g5 is going to be a
permanent problem for him which means if
we can eliminate one of its defenders
either the bishop or the queen
once again we are going to renew the
threat of knight g5 bishop g5 so you can
see how the two sides of the board are
so interconnected a piece that's
you know there's there's this bishop on
e7 which is totally overloaded with two
assignments we're trying to continually
overload it by putting a knight on c5
h4 doesn't do as much as it does in the
game because
since he still has a rook
this doesn't achieve its desired effect
the rook on h8 still guards the h6 pawn
i don't think
it's not a bad move i don't see why we
would need to open the position up this
quickly
because if you compare this to the game
where he blunders the exchange now it's
a much different story because after he
takes
here we can take on h6 and we can
actually infiltrate the king side
tangibly
if you compare that to to this position
his rook is still here this should be
pretty pretty evident at this point
why not knight g5 well if you calculate
you'll see that after bishop g5 bishop
g5 he's not going to take with the pawn
but he is going to take with a queen and
he wins a piece we don't have enough
attackers on on g5 well
zuku but g the problem with h4 isn't
that it hangs upon that's not the issue
the problem is that it doesn't achieve
its desired effect so you can prepare it
all you want
okay great
but still is it it's a little bit
nebulous how you're going to now
infiltrate i guess you can move the king
to h1 and go rook g1 just seems to me to
be a little bit of a clunky planet
although it's also totally possible the
position is so winning that
basically anything uh leads to
infiltration
so after he goes
rook h7 we take oops sorry we take it we
go h4
b4 knight back to e2
and of course we don't care about any of
the pawns here it'll be
like a millennium before his a pawn gets
anywhere near promotion
g6
well just like in a war i mean
infiltration means to to breach the
enemy ranks you know whatever that may
mean in a given position
again we don't play gh we go g6
takes takes we start taking everything
takes the knight and then mate with e6
and bishop f4 so i mean this is all very
simple
uh and and that was the game
no i think that was an instructive game
it was a it was a nice game
and um
yeah i mean once he gave up his rook
the only other instructive move was h4
the rest was very obvious
and this concept of striking when the
iron is hot right that's another
piece of advice i can share if if your
opponent blunders something
particularly material that next move
after you take the material can be very
important because there might
you know either your opponent by tilting
will offer you an opportunity to expand
your advantage or
because he's now lacking that material
you have to understand what bearing that
has on the position so maybe he's lost a
bishop and that bishop was defending a
square which can now be occupied by a
knight so don't simply take the material
and then relax try to understand how
the material
uh gain has impacted the the landscape
of the position if that makes sense
all right
the oh my landscape of the position
well at this point black is totally lost
so at this point i can't offer a good
you know i cannot for good advice but
i i wouldn't go into this opening of
course
but i would probably if i were black i
would go e5 and i would go into an old
indian like down a bunch of tempe but
this is still better than nothing once
he allowed e5 he's basically busted here
it's two there's too many weaknesses
okay guys i would have loved to do
another game but i i need to go to sleep
i've got
a lot of work tomorrow and i've had an
exhausting day today so we're gonna call
it
thank you everybody for for the support
everybody who subs and uh supports the
channel
helps me
with everything i'm gonna head out guys
take care everybody
[Music]